en tout cas beaucoup de Français ont
manifesté et à certains aussi fait grève
la grève a été très suivie ce jeudi et
elle se poursuivra dans certains
secteurs à partir de lundi est-ce que
vous craignez un blocage du pays non je
crains un blocage du débat et ce je suis
très très ferme dessus nous devons
pouvoir avoir un débat sur ce sujet mais
vous savez derrière ces manifestations
qu'on a pu avoir jeudi il faut aussi
entendre la demande l'expression
beaucoup plus générale qui va même
au-delà de la réforme des retraites en
réalité parce que ce qu'on peut entendre
c'est différentes revendications sur des
points que nous devons aussi pouvoir
traiter un sujet sur l'équité ce
sentiment d'injustice qui est très
important et très présent auquel nous
devons répondre de façon très légitime
et claire il y a aussi ce sujet sur le
rapport au travail qui a changé
aujourd'hui on ne considère plus que
réussir sa vie c'est réussir sa carrière
et je dois dire que c'est très bien nous
devons être maintenant sur un rapport au
travail plus juste et enfin peut-être le
plus important dans le cadre actuel de
ces manifestations que nous avons eu
jeudi le rapport au dialogue social ce
dialogue social aujourd'hui doit être
capable de se réinventer parce
qu'aujourd'hui on a l'impression qu'elle
se dialogue social n'a eu lieu que dans
le cadre de ces manifestations c'est
faux nous l'avons dit différents
concertations consultations ont eu lieu
il ne faut pas l'oublier et je dois dire
aussi qu'il y a aussi deux nouvelles
instances de dialogues sociales qui sont
par exemple le Conseil national de leur
à fondation ou les grands débats
[Musique]